ich muss sagen dass weg mindestens 15 15
kilo sind jetzt war mal alarmiert
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu allen neuen video da hatte
ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut heute
haben aber was wirklich sehr sehr
interessantes vor
und zwar habe ich letztens wieder
geschaut was kann man alles auspacken
und im meer wurde das habe ich wurde
wirklich vorgeschlagen keine ahnung
warum aber auf amazon gibt es so naja es
ist keine hysterie boxe ich sag mal so
dieser mystery box hype ist ja auch
verweilt wie viele mystery box wurden in
youtube deutschland schon ausgepackt es
ziemlich viele misery boxen glaube ich
ich habe allerdings heute ein paket
gekauft für 40 euro am 5 ich weiß gar
nicht mehr ganz genau mit 50 insolvenz
produkten hört sich erstmal und
spannender an als es ist auf jeden fall
sind wir in dieser box ganz viele
produkte von unternehmen die insolvenz
gegangen sind oder irgendwie also firmen
beraten
ich weiß gar nicht genau was da drin ist
hat sich auf jeden fall für mich sehr
spannend angehört deswegen habe ich das
gekauft um ein video zu drehen wo ich
das öffnen das ist hier das paket
ich muss sagen dass weg mindestens schon
10 15 kilo sind da drin das ist schon
nicht schlecht
ich glaube auch hier sind über 50
produkte drin stand zumindest in der
beschreibung und ich würde sagen die
lager nicht lange und machen das hätte
man auch hier mit meinem schönen neuen
taschenmesser von wish es schon nicht
schlecht also drückt auf jeden fall mal
das letzte video ab die gefährlichsten
milchprodukte wir können sie auch mal
kurz hier einwenden hier steht merkmale
und details restposten aus insolvenz
produktions und lager über hängen zu
viel produziert und geschäfts auflösung
diese pakete eignen sich ideal für den
wiederverkauf besonders auf märkten für
ihre sonderposten hätte keine ahnung
also was sie für ein gesamter warenwert
drin ist kann ich jetzt so noch gar
nicht sagen steht hier auf jeden fall
nicht bei ihr findet es heraus
vielleicht haben wir hier ein iphone
drücken
ich alle böses wort sich das ausgepackt
habe ist ja weihnachten heute schreibt
er ist in die kommentare was glaubt ihr
wird das wertvoll oder welchen wert hat
das wertvollste produkt da drin da bin
ich mal gespannt schreibt uns in den
kommentaren
wir fangen an hier mit dem er gerade
hierher schon zu viel
wir haben ja einfach eine samsung galaxy
s 4
er wollte ich schon immer haben vor
allem in das samsung galaxy s 4 ist auch
das absolut neueste oder kann man
absolut nichts mit anfangen
hier haben wir also gut jetzt kommt
schon einige heiße sache zum forscher
dass sie ist ich weiß natürlich dass es
so so gummi gummi knete oder hhk
das ist so ja also es fühlt sich schon
ein bisschen ekelhaft an aber wenn man
das hier einmal so durchgeht das könnte
man die gummi ach so hüpft das
im pinken was auch noch dabei das klebt
viel zu hat irgendwie ist sie schlecht
oder so glock nein es sind meine hände
noch hab die es irgendwie schlecht
geworden oder sowas ist das oder ist das
was ich weiß es nicht keine ahnung war
dass der schild auf französisch drauf
gerade mal produkt zwei drei und vier
und zehn helfer so gut machen wir weiter
das kommt auch schnell wieder vom tisch
als nächstes haben hier was ist das denn
sind das zocken made in turkey 12345
paar socken
die nämlich mit ruhig noch gut ich kann
sachen gebrochen also im geschäftsreise
dafür auf jeden fall eine 78 euro würde
ich mal sagen
juli kummer perfektion und verschwanden
das interessante an diesen produkten ist
die kommen aus aller welt dann scheint
nicht nur aus deutschland weil auf
diesen schwenk steht made auf alles auf
türkisch als komme auch aus türkei
bisschen schwimmen hier können wir auf
jeden fall super gut gebrauchen
zumeist schon mal in die küche
eine cd tasche aus welchem jahrhundert
stammt
junge ist das dumm wir brauchen so was
damit man bei der ganzen cd ja auch
immer parat hat braucht kein mensch
weg damit also ich sehe die handy höhen
über handy hüllen bin ich halte das war
immerhin zeigen also sind auf jeden fall
noch eine menge ist eine menge
krimskrams noch drin
viele handy höhen das hier ist eine
flache oder so frankreich klage
allez allez les bleus endlich mal in
frankreich plant habe ich mich schon
ewig gewünscht so als nächstes haben wir
hier
aha dachte gehabt ohne scheiß ich das
rad auf den ersten blick hier werden ein
tablet drin aber es ist einfach nur eine
hülle für das apple ipad 9.7 kann ich
jetzt nicht so viel mit anfangen
irgendwie weil ich habe kein ipad aber
danke dafür kann man sich auf jeden fall
nicht darüber beschweren
ich war jetzt einfach mal alle handy
hüllen hier auf den tisch
okay wir haben hier noch mal sagen so
ein galaxy s 43 nicht dann haben wir
hier lg 3s ich wusste gar nicht dass lg
noch handys macht auf jeden fall habe
ich jetzt eine höhle gefunden die ist
schon ein bisschen hochwertiger muss man
sagen ist was für so soll er entlang von
goldberg sieht nicht schlecht aus fast
jedes handy rein glaube ich dann haben
wir hier nächstes case wieder elche dann
haben wir hier kommen muss ich oder gar
nicht zeigen nächstes produkt akku mal
hier steht sogar noch einen preis drauf
der ist allerdings schon ausgeblichen
von 24 99 runtergesetzt auf 12 euro
mobile alarmsirene sport zur
abschreckung von angreifern die muss ich
mal testen so das ist jetzt dringend was
alarm wir haben sie auf jeden fall
gleich noch lange nicht geschafft
jetzt machen wir ja alle hier scheiß
dich halt an den körper kommen egal hat
ja auch keiner genau so es ist noch
keine lösung nächstes produkt jakob dir
das mal an da ist ein messer drin
damit können wir aus antworten und hier
sind die nächsten wochen das heißt ich
hab jetzt schon zehn paar neue software
in schwarz auch wenn mir weißen socken
eigentlich lieber werden muss ich sagen
aber gut gar kein problem ich junger
alter ist wieder immer dümmer eine
fernbedienung das ist ja so dumm so eine
fernbedienung von so einem alten
fernseher dachdecker hat mal wieder ein
und schickt zurückgekauft hier haben wir
ein lan-kabel ja allerdings in ziemlich
klein naja besser ein kleines kurzes
lang als gar kein laden kamen hat sich
die lösung gefunden
ja das würde ich auf jeden fall
wo die leute merken dass noch also
früher bei uns auf dem schulhof vor dass
die absolute wahnsinn
und hier steht einfach jetzt so gut also
wir hatten jetzt wirklich noch nichts wo
ich gesagt habe damit kann man arbeiten
oder damit kann ich irgendwann anfangen
und es wird auch immer dünner
hier ist irgendwie so ein tannenbaum
schmuck oder so so bei allen war ich
weiß nicht kann ich auch nichts mit
anfangen halt irgendwie ein bisschen lob
hilfe
leute wir haben die lösung gefunden von
dem alarm dinge wenn jemand euch
angreift und ihre dem umfeld
signalisieren wollt bitte helfen sie mir
bitte helfen sie mir
alter ist das laut also dass also wenn
ich jemand angreift wird das für mich
auch direkt zerstören vor allem die laut
das ist alter damit kannst du einen so
aus dem schlaf holen
einfach so ja das gegenteil nächste
handy hülle keine ahnung wo noch mehr
sorgten diesmal in orange sneaker
schuhgröße 35 bis 38 was ich wirklich
ganz neu ist das hier das vielleicht hat
mich die ganze zeit schon so an das ist
glaube ich sogar was dran
nein das kenne ich aus dem urlaub die
habe ich mir früher immer gekauft kann
es halt so ein wasser ziehen muss ich
jetzt hier nicht kennt ja auch hier
davon und schiesst ein bisschen wasser
rein oder insgesamt sind wir bestimmt
schon über den wert von 40 euro
fragt sich nur was es mit dem ganzen
kram soll hier ist das nächste band
ich hätte auch weit scheint kein wunder
warum das darin lange das würde ich auch
nicht kaufen junge störe dieses paket
ist so uralt das ist einfach so eine
schweiz flagge fürs auto wahrscheinlich
wm keine schweiz noch zwei schweiz
flagge und österreich von man waren das
im halb 2006 ich dachte eigentlich dass
in sachen drin die man ein bisschen
brauchen kann so
und das ist gut weil leute ohne scheiß
ich wusste gar nicht dass es so etwas
gibt stecke ich da rein und dann habe
ich schon das problem gelöst wird der
mehrfachsteckdose die ich brauche aber
wir haben ja einen stecker der in zwei
stecker immer gut zu wild da haben wir
hier noch so ein ding ok a portugal
flagge es auch noch das auto und einem
computerkabel okay das hier ist noch was
hier sind so bothe drauf keine ahnung
was du kannst mich jetzt erwartet hier
drin
eine taschenlampe das ist jetzt ein
schrott unboxing hier unglaublich leute
normalerweise seid ihr natürlich von mir
qualitäts an boxing es gewohnt auf
höchstem level das konnte ich ja nicht
ahnen dass uns hier nur scheiße drin
erwartet ohne wird für ihr könnt mal
reinschauen aber hier ist wirklich was
ist das denn stahlwolle die ist wirklich
nur noch höheren pflanzen also ich habe
wirklich gehofft dass das coole sachen
drin sind muss ich sagen ich hoffe ihr
hattet trotzdem bisschen spaß wenn sie
sagt bestellen doch mal weitere
insolvenz waren vielleicht ein bisschen
teurer vielleicht muss ich da auch mal 3
400 euro in die hand nehmen für dann
dass man denken dann nach oben da
ansonsten hoffe ich natürlich jetzt hat
euch trotzdem rivalen checkt die ganzen
letzten videos ab und wir sehen uns dann
hier am sonntag wieder und 19 uhr gibt's
neues video
aber hier den kanal haut rein